[Applause]
history and action are probably two
genres that seem to work so seamlessly
with one another so for today we'll be
talking about what i personally consider
to be some of the most
under appreciated of the mystery action
genre that anime has to offer
now i've already done a video about
mystery thrillers before but i think a
key difference this genre has is its
more pronounced focus on actions fight
scenes
chase scenes and other heart-pounding
scenes often take precedence when a
mystery oftentimes something related to
the origin of the world or the subject
matter in question
hangs in the background a lot of the
most thrilling detective serials fall
into this category
it's no surprise that mystery in action
together have found their way into anime
what's surprising to me however is that
a sizeable portion of viewers are still
not subscribed to this channel
that's why i'd love to encourage you to
hit that subscribe and like button and
help my channel grow
it only takes a second and would do so
much for the
ninth on the channel is blast of tempest
losing a loved one is never easy when
ika
yoshino's girlfriend dies her brother
and yoshino's best friend mahiro
disappears the latter would disappear
and only re-emerge to save yoshino from
a strange girl who has him at gunpoint
my hero has returned a changed man
having enlisted the help of the witch
hakaze to find ikar's killer and deal
with the tree of exodus a gigantic tree
that grants people magic and holds the
key to the destruction of the world
a supernatural action series from late
2012 blast of tempest was probably one
of my favorite bone shows from that era
it keeps you seated and wanting more
with its plot and i really enjoyed the
story due to having quite the passing
interest in classic literature yes
blast of tempest is that it draws a lot
from literary works
specifically the tempest and hamlet
those plays tie in nicely with the
show's themes that focus on escaping the
chains of the past
up next is a more apocalyptic take on
the genre wolf's reign
[Music]
wolf's reign takes us to a world on the
edge of ruin thanks to humanity's greed
and pride the once glorious home planet
has been reduced to a handful of cities
scattered across a barren wilderness
however hope remains in the forms of an
ancient prophecy
that tells of wolves finding their way
to the mystical realm known as paradise
the problem is that no one has seen a
war for ages
the truth is that wars have learned to
disguise themselves in the form of men
existing within society to protect
themselves wolf's reign tells us the
story of one such wolf
kiba and his companions who set off on a
journey to the promised land
however danger lurks at every corner as
it's not just they who want to reach
paradise
coming from cowboy bebop screenwriter
wolf's reign is a gorgeous looking
adventure series that should really be
talked about more
i guess the problem lies in the actual
production itself here that's because
wars reign had a pretty troubled
production
thanks to an ongoing disease outbreak
almost two decades ago guess history
repeats itself doesn't it unfortunately
that's why you should take the time to
watch the ovas that conclude the story
if this series interests you
here's a chinese anime for a change and
it's one of the most popular ones out
there moldovsushi is one of the
excellent chinese novel adaptations that
combine action and asian mysticism
thirteen years before the start of the
story wei strayed down the path of evil
and unleash destruction his reign of
terror would be put to a stop but he
reincarnates in the present day and
reunites with his former classmate lang
wangji the two then move to uncover the
truth to a dark energy and a
supernatural mystery that begins
plaguing the numerous clans thanks to
its intriguing plot and
excellent art the series received much
critical acclaim however
still so little talk about it it
certainly felt so underrated given the
reception when it was first being
released if you happen to enjoy modal
sushi you can enjoy the story in its
numerous other adaptations
such as the webcomic or the drama
up next is eden of the east careless
monday a missile strike on japan with
miraculously no casualties everyone
moved over it and it seemed like a
distant
irrelevant event for people including
saki morimi what wasn't irrelevant
however is her encounter with a naked
amnesiac with a gun and a cell phone in
the united states things
will just get worse for saki she quickly
finds herself embroiled in a death game
involving money and the fate of the
world what will become of the duo and
the battles against fellow
phone-wielding individuals they now find
themselves in how does this all connect
to careless monday you're gonna have to
watch the show to find
out it's the second mystery action anime
featuring death games and cell phones
and i think the eden of the east
compared to darwin's game leans more on
the mystery side of things with each
episode you get the urge to want more
with every episode thanks to how the
suspense gets built up in its time
2009 it's also very novel as an idea and
i think that it still holds true to a
lesser extent now
[Music]
halfway into the list is land of the
lustrous in the future
crystalline life forms called gems
inhabit a mysterious world where they
must find the lunarians a species that
kidnaps them and turns them into jewelry
foss one of the gems longs to join the
battle but thanks to their condition is
forcibly relegated into the furthest job
from such a desire a historian
being assigned to compile the history of
the world is a mundane and pointless
task for a lot of them but
the new job sends foss into contact with
cinnabar seeing the mutual unhappiness
in cinema
foss decides to help the fellow gym find
a role for them to enjoy
what adventures await the duo land of
the lustrous for me
shines in its handling of its world it's
set in a very fantastical world with
very interesting residents that you
can't help but want to know about it's
got some action blended into the very
meaningful plot and despite lacking
initial hype
is one of the best mystery action anime
out there seriously people need to
appreciate this one a lot more
at number four is glipener
[Music]
how about another one spring 2020
sleeper hit glipenir shuichi may seem to
be your ordinary student but he just
gets the ability to turn into a fursuit
monster he doesn't know how he got the
powers
nor does he want anything to do with
them however an encounter with claire
exposes his secret and lets him know
claire's secret of her own
has been long looking for her sister who
also turned into a monster together the
two form an unlikely duo out to search
for the truth behind monsters claire's
sister
and the shuichi's powers aliens
otherworldly abominations
transforming people everything goes in
this grim and deadly mystery for a lot
of you who haven't watched the anime
your exposure to glipener probably came
from videos talking about its amazingly
animated fight scenes however if you go
beyond the fights
i think that the plot is very intriguing
and seeing the character dynamics in
play make gleipner a winner in my book
it may seem like an edge fest but
it's actually a lot more profound than
it seems to be a first
watch
[Music]
[Applause]
third place for the list is arjin 17
years prior mysterious humans known as
arjun made their presence felt in africa
since then they've been classified as a
top level threat and the world has
mobilized to eradicate them or take them
into custody the world has been kept
free of them to the point where aspiring
doctor kane the guy knew little of them
when he survived an accident and is
reborn as one of them now with a target
on his back
k finds himself on the run as he looks
to uncover the truth behind these super
creatures slowly realizing that maybe
the real monsters aren't as far away
from humanity as he once thought i've
made it clear in some of my previous
videos that when it comes to
action-packed thrillers that have an air
of mystery arjun is one of my favorite
anime of
all time the cg might take a bit of time
to get used to but don't be deterred by
that
after all you'd be missing out on one of
2016's hits that skillfully combined
action
suspense unraveling twists and a rather
profound take on humanity's nature
who says that we're done with literature
references blast of tempest had some
callbacks to a literary work but how
about an entire series focused on actual
authors of your favorite literary
masterpieces
oh and give them cool powers to boot due
to incidents involving a tiger
atsushi finds himself kicked out of his
orphanage and left a vagabond in the
streets of japan his seemingly mundane
life comes to an end when he saves
supernatural detective osamu dazai from
drowning the detective's investigation
on the tiger puts atsushi in quite the
bind and the latter finds himself
forcibly pulled into the world of
supernatural investigations and battles
combining the aesthetics of the early
1900s with the modern japan setting
ended up being a good call and i found
myself thoroughly immersed in the story
thanks to the cool developments and the
powers i'm not sure if i really consider
bungo stray dogs to be underappreciated
because it does have a fan base
however for how great it is i thought
that this would have been the next big
thing
so if you're up for some urban action
fantasy i heartily recommend this show
to you
the number one underappreciated mystery
action anime for this list is
garden of sinners
have you heard of this one before
constantly a type moon fan favorite
garden of sinners is a series of movies
chronicling a string of baffling
suicides in japan to investigate the
events a detective agency dispatches the
dynamic duo of mikia goguto and shiki
ryogi
a contrasting duo of a normal boy and
girl wielding the mystic eyes of death
they have their work cut out for them
watch as the two of them were to get to
the bottom of the mysterious suicides
that have ravaged the country
garden of sinners prides itself in its
unorthodox watch order and the numerous
layers that can be peeled from its story
it could be a standard paranormal
investigation story
but it could also be interpreted as
people coming to terms with life and
death it's not an easy watch
being dark and twisted a lot of times
but in terms of considering anime as a
profound piece of philosophy and
art garden of sinners is probably one of
the best bets to support this point
for fans of the mystery action genre
these are the shows you may have missed
and may want to keep an eye out for for
those who've already watched the shows
which ones are your favorites please
don't hesitate to tell me also if you've
had fun with the video
i'd like you to also check out my
patreon i'll be leaving a link in the
description box below and you can follow
the link and start supporting this
channel
your help would really be appreciated so
what's next for vinnie tube you better
hit that subscribe button so that you
can be the first in line whenever i
upload a new video what i can guarantee
is that i'll keep giving you these anime
recommendations and i hope that you'll
enjoy the next video
as much as the previous ones till next
time
you